okay  and i have some exciting news for you  actually because alireza made a move  yeah bishop c1 was played actually yeah  okay so knight d7  knight to d takes d7 and we didn't look  at this one so much did we uh  i think we talked about it we didn't  talk about this maybe we didn't  knight d7 now the question is well of  course queen d7 has to be the first move  to call  to consider  looks the most natural i mean is he  worried about but you know even king d7  is possible oh  but first of course you think this  oh  maybe it's exaggerating i don't know  [Laughter]  didn't even enter my radar shooting  this is what it takes to be  a grand master unexpected king moose you  know something quite funny